bonsoir michel larive merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france pourquoi avoir publié
cette tribune la singette alpes
potentiellement dangereux selon vous
alors oui potentiellement vers longtemps
bull
la problématique est la suivante c'est
que cette potion potentialités n'a pas
été étudiée aucun rapport gouvernemental
nous dit cette peur cette dangerosité
potentielle média + chargeur problème un
problème d'abord écologique
c'est une technologie à haute fréquence
donc il faut multiplier les antennes
ensuite on utilise d'autres matériels et
son avant de construire d'autres
matériels on aura donc un besoins
énergétiques énormes
par exemple en chine la nuit on est
incessante m ensuite la menace pour me
données personnelles l'interconnexion
c'est que les états pourront avoir accès
à vos données personnelles via d'autres
applications
les états là mais aussi de grandes
multinationales comme les guerres femmes
et puis la dépendance technologique
étrangères c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
la france et l'europe en général n'a pas
bouclé son protocole singer donc nous
sont dépendants d'une technologie
étrangère notamment peut-être de huawei
qui est numéro un mondial
la dessus mais aussi des américains qui
veulent absolument tes soucis danto
choisissent une technologie occidentale
et puis et puis et puis il y à cet enjeu
démocratique
les gars sa sortie un rapport dont on
n'a pas accès et s'éteint c'est un
problème la france a soumis sa demande
de voir l'accès d'avoir accès à ce
rapport et nous demandons qu'il soit dès
que discuter de ceux ci devant la
représentation nationale donc devant
nous parlementaires à minimes 1 je vous
rappelle quand même que les citoyens
dans la convention citoyenne d'un homme
qui a été posée par monsieur le
président l'a appelé dernièrement ont
posé quelques questions et mis en
suspens comme ce déploiement de cinq
jeux c'est pourquoi nous demandons un
moratoire s'agit pas ici de s'opposer
aux progrès technologiques aux
scientifiques
il s'agit de savoir quels seront les
impacts de ce progrès technologique et
scientifique sur nos sociétés
et vous demandez également est ce que
les citoyens participent aux débats à
l'instar de ce qui s'est fait pour pour
l'écologie oui bien entendu bien entendu
aujourd'hui on nous impose ceci regarder
même les grands opérateurs français
disent qu'ils devraient être levés pied
dans le sens où le 29 septembre le
gouvernement décide d'ouvrir le
lancement des enchères pour les
attributions de fréquences pour pouvoir
essayer de mettre que la technologie 5 g
soit opérationnel en france à la fin de
l'année c'est très rapide et se faire
louis ii et puis d'autres disent que
c'est très rapide que le toute manière
et ne pourront pas même si le s'ils ont
les fréquents ce pouvoir suivre l'agenda
gouvernemental
alors moi je me pose quand même la
question pourquoi pourquoi le
gouvernement allait si vite
nous avons des discussions avec nos
partenaires allemands nos partenaires
européens sur cette problématique
faudrait peut-être attendre ces retours
déjà et comme être un petit peu quel
sera le plan de marche de cette
technologie et je vous le rappelle les
impacts démocratiques sociaux de liberté
écologique sur nos sociétés
d'autant qu'il y à encore là de la 4g
sur le territoire de la 3g delà d'eux
mêmes c'est cet empilement aussi de
technologies qui pose problème pour
l'écologie oui vous avez raison et ça va
même plus loin
alors vous savez moi je suis de l'ariège
le député député de la seconde
circonscription de l'ariège la 4g n'est
pas complètement déployé en ariège comme
dans d'autres départements plutôt ruraux
et puis on nous propose déjà la 5g et
puis en chine et dans des pays
asiatiques depuis 2010 neuf il ya des
groupes de travail sur la cij est donc
en fait l'avenir et peut-être vers la 6e
ou d'autres technologies et on me
demande de déployer la 5g alors pourquoi
pas mais deux
l'idée c'est de savoir quels sont les
tenants et les aboutissants est surtout
c'est une idée aussi de souveraineté
populaire
les citoyens comme vous l'avez
pertinemment dit on le droit ont le
droit de savoir quelles seront les
conséquences de ces interconnexions pour
leur vie c'est à dire que qu'elle est
l'intrusion que va générer cette
nouvelle technologie
j'ai pu le voir dans d'autres pays que
l'inclusion et véritable c'est à dire
qu'il ya un protocole de surveillance
généralisée qui se met en place
malgré nous la 5g à la possibilité
technologique de le faire
donc elle le feu merci beaucoup michel
larive d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur rt france